machen wir uns nichts vor weihnachten
ist in gefahr möglicherweise doch wieder
kontakt beschränkungen verwandte treffen
nur wenn sie gebucht sind und an der
geschenke front sieht auch düster aus ja
es ist so denn zu allem anderen erleben
wir auch noch eine globale lieferkette
alles möglich ist aktuell kaum noch
lieferbar der wahre geist der weihnacht
also hemmungsloser konsum ist akut
bedroht das weihnachtsfest mit oma opa
tante onkel kindern wackelt genauso wie
der weihnachtsmarkt bummeln und jetzt
auch noch dass die gänse werden knappe
der braten teuer so jetzt reicht's
ab jetzt ist es persönlich weihnachten
ohne ganz klar zur not kann man
irgendwie improvisieren sie können sich
zum beispiel unauffällig das
meerschweinchen ihrer kinder line
kurz frittieren paar chicken wings als
flügel daran dass merck kein mensch
in peru eine spezialität nennt noch
dramatischer ist aktuell die sache mit
den deutschen weihnachtsmärkten die in
bayern wurden heute alle abgesagt andere
finden vielleicht erst mal statt aber
mit einschränkungen hier ein betroffener
berichtet es findet ein weihnachtsmarkt
statt aber ohne weihnachtsmann das finde
ich wirklich nicht in ordnung
nicht lachen wo wir gerade dabei sind
noch eine schlechte nachricht nicht
gibt's gar nicht ja ja das ist der
weihnachtsmann aus celle der dieses jahr
kein witz weihnachtsmarkt verbot mit der
begründung er würde zu viele leute
anlocken dachte das wäre sein beruf
natürlich ist das mit den
weihnachtsmärkten eine schwierige
abwägung ist ja völlig klar
alkoholisierte menschenmassen helfen der
infektions lage nicht wirklich deshalb
setzten einige städte noch auf zweig und
woanders gibt sogar extra bereiche nur
für ungeimpfte ist wirklich wahr dass
auf der einen seite top laune dann
glühwein mit schuss
auf der anderen man kann auch ohne
alkohol fröhlich sein
leipzig hatte eigentlich den plan 0 g
sogar ohne masken pflicht stattdessen
stattdessen setzt man auf sogenannte
verfall und flaniert zonen in den
flaniert zonen soll bewegung herrschen
kontrolliert durch sicherheitspersonal
und die polizei ja ganz neues konzept
die leipziger flaniert zonen ob das
funktionieren kann gute fragen sie
sie sie stellt sich nur leider gar nicht
mehr den kurz vor der aufzeichnung
unserer sendung kam die meldung dass
auch sachsen wohl alle weihnachtsmärkte
ab sagt bitter sehr bitter weihnachten
steht auf der kippe und wegen der
gestörten lieferketten kriegen viele von
uns am ende wieder nur doofe gutscheine
geschenkt total euro
wer sich jetzt zum beispiel ein fahrrad
wünscht ich sage ihnen keine chance der
fahrradmarkt liest man wird sich
frühestens
2024 wieder normalisieren fahrräder
unterhaltungselektronik vergiss es
einfach lieferprobleme bei ikea bei
douglas in baumärkten mit anderen worten
wer die bescherung noch retten will muss
kreativ werden zwei tipps von mir im
laden gibt es nur noch ein fahrrad aber
sie haben zwei kinder
na und dann kriegen eben beide jeweils
ein cooles einrad problem gelöst und es
muss auch gar nicht immer die ständig
ausverkaufte playstation fünf sein
stattdessen schickt man einfach die
playstation 2 und playstation 3 macht
zusammen auf 5
aber machen wir uns nichts vor auch
weihnachten 2021 wird garantiert kein
normales wir schon mal live in die
privatwohnung unseres kollegen martin
klempnow der mit seiner familie bereits
heute also am 19 november weihnachten
feiern martin warum warum ich
nachrichten gucken sie haben es doch
selber gesagt heiligabend gibt es
garantiert keine geschenke mehr und
bevor mir meine frau wieder so einen
tollen gutschein für eine nackenmassage
schenk ja kein vorwurf
absolut ein vorwurf bringen wir das
jetzt heute hinter uns ich bestimme wann
weihnachten ist noch feuerzangenbowle
jemand ja gern aber
erklärt
für uns geimpfte könnte es doch noch ein
relativ normales weihnachten werden ja
genau und maria bauer und jungfrau er
verstehe denke schon in wenigen tagen
stehen die uhren wieder auf lockdown für
alle plus ausgangssperre und warum weil
nichts anderes mehr hilft und weil wir
den sommer verpennt haben jede wette
weit stehen sie wieder da im fernsehen
wie die orgelpfeifen und singen im chor
wenn wir jetzt kämpfen wenn wir jetzt im
november gut durchhalten wir kämpfen
jetzt darum dass wir wirklich
weihnachten feiern können dass wir da
ein gutes weihnachtsfest feiern können
weihnachten ist auch
eigentlich das wichtigste festival
entschuldigung er kommt gerade von
dominosteine hoch weihnachts schmalz und
vom eigenen versagen abzulenken alles
setzte vom letzten jahr die in wenigen
tagen garantiert wieder aktuell sind
einmal noch die zähne zusammenbeißen
blablabla kurzer spoiler wenn wir unsere
impflücken nicht irgendwie schließen
wird gar nichts besser dann werden
kapsel und winter ab jetzt immer kacke
und zwar jedes jahr das steht mir die
leute doch jetzt ein bisschen zu sehr
unter wir brauchen doch eine
konstruktive perspektive und die habe
ich
wir feiern einfach jetzt schon alles was
demnächst so anfällt ja weil es jetzt
noch geht verstehen sie hintereinander
alles weg von aus tempo los leid der
familie heiligabend
ach ist das schön zusammen
nach erreicht bescherung
woher steffi die teuren fußball schuhe
die ich mir selber ausgesucht und
bestellt und dazu noch bezahlt habt du
bist du verrückt sei silvester
frohes neues jahr
mensch mutti du wirst doch im märz 80
und hast aber noch kein bus dorthin also
feiern wir auf sicher heute falls du
vorher an
happy birthday to you tube mutter du
bist was jetzt noch stimmt im januar da
ist doch dieser schwedische knut tag wo
man die weihnachtsbäume aus dem fenster
das weiß keiner eine zweite katze raus
sagt er
in dieser sekunde fällt mir das
wichtigste fest ein
steffi wir wollten uns doch nächstes
jahr scheiden lassen wenn der junge
endlich sein abi hat was weißt du was
ich ziehe einfach jetzt schon aus ja
ohne quatsch erwecke das ist jetzt schon
das schönste weihnachten das ich jemals
hatte
martin klempnow viele
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mime hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
scheiß und sie töten - wollt dann
abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]